kann das heute abend die trendwende
gewesen sein der kofler wir haben hier
im studio schon darüber gesprochen aber
auch eben als wir sind kleiner runde
geschaut haben ist das eine fragerunde
bei der man als normaler bürger folgen
kann und weiß okay jetzt weiß ich woran
ich bin für die nächsten vier jahre in
meinem land
naja ich glaube es sind viele fragen
viele fragen angesprochen worden
eine habe ich vermisst nämlich das thema
sicherheit innere sicherheit und äußere
sicherheit auch dem militär
militärpolitik zum beispiel wie schützen
wir deutschland in zukunft
aber insgesamt glaube ich konnten die
bürger schon folgen es war nicht diese
dramatische auseinandersetzung die man
sich zu diesem zeitpunkt im wahlkampf an
den wünschen müssen ja man ich
persönlich muss auch sagen die feuerwehr
barg war erinnere wirklich geradezu
spürbar kontodaten situationen in beiden
streithähne neben ihr haben sich da
wunder gegeben und sie konnten dann
immer sehr weise und sehr auf ihre these
bezogen agieren also sie war hier quasi
ein bisschen panik strukturellen vorteil
und deswegen hätte ich wirklich gut
gefunden wenn wir einfach pech gehabt
denn wo christian lindner hofft dabei
gewesen wäre hätten wir eine viel
ausgegeben da stand unter
unterschiedlichen positionen haben und
ich fand das wäre auch wichtig gewesen
um diese möglichen koalitionspartner
leicht die sich da ja noch frei und weil
ich zu können vielleicht sieht er noch
vor bayern den grünen möglich ist es
noch einmal schnell eine politische
frage an den experten béla anda ganz am
anfang wurde amila stadt gefragt würden
sie auch als juniorpartner in eine
regierung olaf scholz eintreten und er
wollte das nicht ausschließen warum um
gottes willen wollte er das nicht
ausschließen weil er das nicht
ausschließen kann weil es für ihn eine
mögliche option ist das ist mir übrigens
aufgefallen bei dem bild duell da hat
befragt von paul ronzheimer armin
laschet und damals war ja vier wochen er
schon einen ganz starken momente gehabt
und gesagt er war doch eigentlich immer
jemand der sich um außenpolitik
gekümmert hat dann habe ich gedacht mein
gott warum betont er das so und
vielleicht
8 ist dass wir ihnen eine rolle die als
vizekanzler in einer möglichen großen
koalition eingehen will aber das war
natürlich noch viel zu früh und war
nicht von umfragen gestützt jetzt kommen
wir mehr in diese richtung und er muss
die cdu an die macht führen und wenn es
nur eine zeile macht ist ist es für die
partei immer noch besser denke ich als
in der opposition zu sein denn die ist
bekanntlich mist
rosi körper opposition ist mist aber
eine cdu als juniorpartner
der armin laschet als vizekanzler für
sie vorstellbar
das sind eben diese machte
machiavellistischen dieses klein-klein
posten geschiebe ich finde das
interessant was thomas gottschalk vom
tier verrät schaut vorhergesagt hat
nämlich was ist das ziel eigentlich so
eine sachdiskussion es geht ja auch
darum die menschen zu inspirieren und es
geht darum sie zu berühren und sich
nicht in diesen chefbeamten es im
fachchinesisch zu verlieren diesen
schlaftabletten sound der irgendwann
wenn da noch der begriff digitalisierung
feld das er wird das wie eine art dem
beruhigungs medikament liegt also eine
sendung und man fühlt der innere
traumwelt zu zählen lösche hätte doch
jetzt aufzeigen müssen dass er in allen
wesentlichen fragen auf die strafraum
kommt eine andere richtung für
deutschland an die und da ist zum
beispiel in der klimadebatte hat er sich
total aufs glatteis führen lassen er war
nicht zu unterscheiden und frau berger
war nicht zu unterscheiden von hergés
der wieder brillant das prinzip
langeweile sich auf die fahnen
geschrieben hat er ist ein kandidat der
gar nicht zu seiner eigenen partei aus
die eigene partei will ihn gar nicht
also man braucht immer was ist das
eigentlich aber laschet hätte hier
aufzeigen müssen wohin geht die reise
mit ihm er hätte das profil zeigen
müssen aber das hat er eben diese chance
hat er nicht gebracht hat nicht
angeschlossen an das was er am samstag
er irgendwo in ansätzen dann doch
gezeigt habe bedauerlich für die ihr auf
die zeiten hoffen
[Musik]